all right i'll trust you but if you're
gonna blend in
you gotta blend in if you like pina
coladas
and getting caught in the rain
you two are looking good really kind of
feel like i'm
jimmy buffett's tennis coach no it's
working you know i had a major crush on
magnum p.i
major oh should i grow a mustache yeah
you should we're gonna need disguises
and since we're going to a public
library the best way to fit in is as
scholars weird perverts yes weird
perverts is far better
far better
[Music]
what is the bandwidth on the wi-fi here
we have much
content to stream
here's my cover my name is sherwin
lemonde sculptor
painter full-time barista but once i
sell my first piece
part-time barista oh nice i'm donald
hoberman's sites
i wear glasses is that all you got sorry
i spent the cab right here imagining me
and genevieve kissing okay just let me
do the talking
wine yes thank you so much oh wow i love
your outfit
i'm an artist so i get that it's more
than just tight nick likes to coat women
in latex
he's fascinated by the idea of the human
chrysalis and society's pupation
hmm cool human chrysalis and whatnot you
know
you know what not to what not no
no i have no idea what a chrysalis is
but serious question if she farts in
that thing does it blow up like a
balloon
you have to assume that it would you
have to right
what are you looking at mcallister
terry terry terry i need you to help me
see what i'm not seeing
why can't you do this you're giving me
too many notes okay well then i can boil
it down for you
into one note tyrone is an ocean i don't
know what that means it means i want you
to be tough but vulnerable brave but
scared jittery but perfectly still
also pace it up a little come on buddy
you got this man these stupid cops won't
leave me alone what the hell they think
i'm a snitch
not me i gotta have mcallister i need to
talk no
excuse me i don't want any more notes
i've gone undercover before let's just
back off and let me do this
uh-oh alfonso seems as though we got a
pig in our midst
looks like we can only trust each other
come on man you're obviously a cop too
keep talking how nefarious you are so
nikki i always want to get my hair cut
here
everyone says you're the best oh my god
i love your earrings where did
you get those hoops um i don't know
oh no nikki's not a talker we're screwed
don't worry angel
gina's got this crackity crack
rosa repeat after me and don't change a
thing
can i tell you the craziest story one
time i was like
so drunk and this meathead comes up to
me and his body is
hot but his face is like okay so i'm
like why and i was like
[ __ ] i'm not gonna sleep with you just
because you promised to take me to the
bahamas
take me to the bahamas first and then
we'll see what happens okay
i was only with him because he drove a
jaguar
turns out it was mercury with a
thundercat taped to the hood and that
relationship
lasted for three months i don't know why
we broke up i guess we just grew apart
when he went to prison for life i hear
that
the guy i'm seeing is into some shady
stuff
right there it is the breakthrough
follow up follow up
so how'd you guys meet that's a funny
sorry
the next time you're all done and you
look hot girl no no she was opening up
rosa figure out a way to stay in that
chair hey nikki
i was just wondering how do you think i
would look
as a blonde like danielle's steel novel
oh i used to see my boyfriend on friday
nights after his wife went to bed
but then he left town a couple of weeks
ago
y'all's on here gorgeous
i love it uh uh but finish what you were
saying uh where'd your boyfriend run off
to
ugh that is the story for next time
we're so close you can't leave
tell her you want a perm i want a perm
a big old perm great idea
forget ann who should we fix him up with
huh oh now sal you know i'm still
getting over the tragedy loss of my wife
she was such a strong female woman with
nice heavy breasts
who's that oh that's my neighbor hey
larry
ah hey grab greg
ah that was it i'm not sure why i have
so much trouble remembering probably
because our relationship is so casual
i am herbert goffelman from san diego i
came here to stand in the cold outside
the today show holding a sign with a
misspelled word on it
oh you know what you win that neon green
fanny pack screams gullible tourist
it's mine i brought it from home
hi there we'd like to go to the times
square we're brothers
[Music]
hey we would like to buy some bagels
and where is the sex of the city street
we want to see where carrie and big live
i'ma carry i think i'm gonna carry we're
both carries
all right let's go over our covers one
more time we are small time operators
that just moved here from miami we
piloted go fast boats moving contraband
to cuba well we slept with the same
prostitute no and she said you were the
best she ever had maybe and i should
watch you to learn
back to no let's just not talk about our
sex lives all right we've got a week
so we can use our way into this thing
let's not blow it by engaging right away
oh no we made eye contact he's coming
over here we're engaging right away
hey what's going on i saw you guys
staring at me what
no no no no we were just looking at the
tv behind you we love finding bigfoot
it's our favorite show yeah i mean why
haven't they caught him yet right
i don't know is anyone gonna buy it i
mean do i look pregnant
i mean i guess i can see it
i think it's amazing oh jake and amy and
baby makes three
i don't know if i believe in god but i
have prayed for this
that is psychotic all right ames let's
go over your cover story again
okay my name is isabel cortez i'm in for
murder
cause some perv on the subway tried to
touch me and i was like
did someone order a tracheotomy okay i
think that's a little too technical we
need to work on your tough talks so
what are you in for cortez none of your
damn business nice
keep going with that i'm gonna split you
like a sunday with grandpa
[ __ ] okay i think the [ __ ] part was
great yeah
although mean threats generally don't
involve having desserts with your
grandparents so
just try again keep telling me what to
do and i'll stab your face off okay
oh yes like that jake you need a jacket
or something well scully let's sports
coat back there
oh but it'll never fit jake's athletic
body unless
no i don't want to do that you have to
i'm not gonna do it
you're doing it what what do you have to
do don johnson it's in it
[Music]
i look like an idiot i didn't even have
time to lotion my forearms
augustine took the laptop case with him
he's gonna make the drop let's go
look there's the buyer or maybe he's
just actually saying hi to the chef
why isn't he making the handoff oh crap
he saw us uh
excuse me oh hey we were just
looking for a place to uh boink
yep boink that's my preferred term for
it as well
so here's how our thing is gonna go
every hotel safe has an override code in
case guests leave them locked
that code is kept on the concierge's
computer
do you know this is this is matt daniel
the most popular male asmr performer on
twitch
asmr performer someone who speaks real
soft i also crinkle paper we're trying
to stream and the noise on the eighth
floor is unacceptable
my fans can't hear my mouth i'm so sorry
i can't hear you that's the point
georgina he says that's the point
georgina this is taking too long make a
video
tell your 25 million subscribers to
never
stay at this crap hotel no no no i'll
take care of it
let me talk to my general manager you
better run matt don't yell
you strain your beautiful voice hi
i'm jake peralta all right so thrilled
to be here today
uh as many of you may know i used to be
a cop
hey i was dirty i took tons of bribes
but as a former detective uh i know a
thing or two about life sentences
and angie marco
you just got slapped with the best life
sentence there is
marriage
to angie and marco make us proud have a
son
[Music]
hey i love the spray tan joey hey let me
take a picture of you i want to show
this color to the guy who stains my deck
congratulations tony it's a beautiful
night
hey you're one of us now
you know how long i've been waiting for
one of you old men to kiss me he's a
good kid
i gotta say out of the four you i think
vito's the best kisser
ah what a wedding huh although the
meatballs were a little dry
dry meatballs that's peralta's signal
let's go let's go
nobody say anything nobody talks get
your hands
off of the use pizza hey captain holt
long time no see how you doing this is
not the time peralta oh yeah that's the
stuff
i've missed us
you